[Music]
in is it fair news no my life's not fair
next video done submitted by eat veggies
I do I love veggies I haven't either
single-ended a I don't like veggies at
all
there it is skip that part of my please
you had a pickle oh that's right
I had a nod is that a fruit cuz I has
sea cucumber is cucumber a fruit or a
vegetable vegetable yeah because it's
green no because but you have the seeds
does it grow out of the ground this is a
really dumb conversation there's a hot
dogger sandwich exactly no I love hot
dogs a mom is suing her son's school
over the soccer teams tryout rules know
how to kick a ball what else know this
one
so this story here in Missouri takes
place in Missouri this mom took her case
to federal court
Wow her son who's named John Doe did not
make the varsity soccer team and was not
allowed to play on the JV team so the
school says that if a junior does not
make the varsity team you can't play on
the junior varsity team and that they do
that to allow lower grade students a
chance to develop their skills so they
can be prepared to try out for varsity
or mean yeah it should be the best only
if you're not the best at being varsity
then the best at being in junior varsity
I'm agree with you yeah David you don't
think about that David that's wrong man
he didn't make it so he couldn't go to
the D he already played on the junior
varsity team so you suck there no no I
mean he was okay
cuz he played on the team and then so
when you tried out for the varsity mmm
like nice so if he never would have
tried could he have stayed on junior
varsity that's what it seems like but
then see this is kind of contradicting
no because they saying that they don't
have a policy keeping juniors from
playing JV sports it just depends how
many kids go out for a certain sport no
he's a junior he's played in the JV but
then he tried out for varsity no you're
not letting him play hey guys explain me
what the [ __ ] varsity judo varsity all
that [ __ ] is and like look great you
gotta be [ __ ] for like it's varsity is
like the dopest one-bar series like the
NFL and then junior so if your senior or
freshman or junior doesn't matter you're
you get to be varsity if you're good
yes yeah okay cuz I had a friend and it
was a big deal in June freshman that he
was able to play it was also like a
six-foot Samoan boy at 14 years old so
yeah yeah being a freshman and taking
senior classes yeah so this is what it
is
so varsity you have to try out alright
so that is a in this tournaments like
this it's an elite set of athletes
within your school right depending on
what level is that like you're having at
school team yes tryout junior varsity is
where people get developed you don't
really have the tryout you just have to
go through the motions and you could
join it depending on how many slots they
have yeah I mean you still trapping they
will cut it off if you're not good
enough for JV so like if you're trash
you can't get into JV hey so I'm like
for me if I wanted to be like in JV
basketball in high school I probably
could've got it right but if you want to
go for varsity you can but usually what
happens is like if you're a junior
you're not gonna want to play JV
football either way yes you know so this
kid he's a senior he still wants played
JV soccer it's like number one that's a
little weird yeah just JV usually for
freshmen and sophomores to develop eclis
so then when they get into junior I mean
uh what is it what's the 11th grade
doing you're junior right yeah it was
yeah yeah freshman sophomore junior
senior right so that when you're junior
senior then you want to play varsity I
mean you can technically have somebody
who's like a junior senior play
versity but it's like why didn't you
quit but I give up give up and quit so
so freshman and sophomore most people
that don't know the sport but want to
get good at it they develop their time
there and in they apply for varsity ok
or they just want to play once and leave
it at that
I see didn't like that why now she can't
he can't even play at all like he can't
try like playing on JV and get ready for
the next year you try for varsity but he
couldn't get in and then they wouldn't
even let him play junior varsity and
they're like move it for a freshman or
sophomore that wants to get yeah so now
she took this all the way to federal
court that's weird that it's going to
federal court but but that's so dumb on
her as a [ __ ] parent because now
you're making your kid look like a
[ __ ] loser the lawyer said because
when they interviewed the lawyer the
lawyer was like no the boy wanted us to
take it this far he wants to but that's
what the lawyer says oh [ __ ] I believe
it when I was in med White House all
right there was this kid that was 400
[ __ ] pounds right he could not get a
vest that I'll attached all the way to
the back and the mob sat there and
demanded that he get a best with the
back on it and I had to tell her I'm
sorry your son is 400 pounds we don't
have a vest above XXXL you know and the
kids sitting there with his head down
embarrasses [ __ ] you know anything yeah
and then you get a whiteboard no here's
why it's mathematically impossible like
I'm [ __ ] Neil deGrasse Tyson the beds
like ready hi three times one for this
is above that pal but that's what it
reminds me of you know what I mean and
also to listen think about it like this
there are freshmen and sophomores that
want best spot so you've had your glory
you know and now that is time for you to
move on let these other kids because
they aren't on in other spots let them
have their time too but if you wanted to
try out in the next year in senior year
he doesn't even have the chance to get
better and right through JV this he's
not going he's not going to come if he's
been doing JV for the last I've even do
JV for three years he hasn't gotten
better he's not going to but what if he
just loves to play soccer
they could play with friends yeah play
with your friends go to the park he only
did it for two years
well there's beads outside of high
school that they couldn't exactly a
hundred percent so I receiving people
outside of high school and college that
join different kind of sport leagues
like like our friend has a basketball
league he's in his thirties and he plays
but I don't understand how they can win
in a federal court there's no federal
law saying like you must allow juniors
to play JV it's probably some
discrimination because it's counter
intuitive what the mom is assuming for
cause she's saying this is an age and
sex discrimination because she says that
the girls team doesn't have the same
rules that there's not enough of them
plays because nobody watches they do
have it you are on one today Sue's
nobody watches to those teams no I'll
put it a letter because you don't have
any hand-eye coordination damn straight
I am
I'm absolutely better they're talking
about fair treatment then so let's put
it on the other side right what about
those other kids who just came to school
and he's taking up that spot when he
only had two years to play JV and they
can't play because of him because he
didn't do better because he did yeah
yeah so how's that fair then so maybe
they should go ahead and to go to
federal court for that boys exactly my
whole thing is that there's no laws like
how are you gonna go there's no [ __ ]
case claim you can be mad oh you want
I'll get mad about things yes I'm a
mother so I wouldn't know how this but
why are there some moms out there that
try to bend the rules to let their kids
win instead of making it hard for their
parent I mean for their kids so then
they could become better human beings
have you seen other kids you don't
understand I'm like I'm a mom and I
wouldn't do that I don't understand
either
well you're but you're in that world
right like what you you actually have a
kid you could you go to the PTAs or
whatever you've seen other parents and
[ __ ] like that I just can't be in that
even close to it so I just can't even
nobody you are you're forgetting that
not everyone's raising good human beings
truth you know I'm saying that's the
main point some people like this mom is
teaching her son a great lesson that
might actually help him get ahead in
life later like Sue and [ __ ] with people
and like all this [ __ ] and stomp on
people to win but like like you said we
all see it as like that's that
you know what I'm gonna do like like for
my kid right let's say this so he passes
algebra okay you know he goes over to
Stuart I want the algebra again I'm like
go ahead dude four years in a row go do
that he's being out for before us bucket
you know I mean like I think that's kind
of stupid like I just it doesn't make
any sense to me like I'm not saying the
kid sucks at what he does but you had
your chance you had your chance they'll
give that opportunity of the case of
that ultra prize have a chance at
algebra I failed Spanish won three times
they should not have let me in the
Spanish one reason all right I was I
could I couldn't even get into JV
Spanish right and I'm trying to give him
Spanish 3 4 which is jord varo Spanish
no dude I would get my ass whooped if I
got an F in something I just picked her
Steve like taking Spanish one at like 18
years old and as he leaves it classy
goes hola como CD say this whole [ __ ]
quiz you came home with your grades and
it said F on Spanish in your and parents
was like that's like he's creative no it
wasn't good it wasn't good I got
grounded and [ __ ] all the time it was
not good yeah for a flagel that's
exactly what have you that's exactly
what is this is crazy cuz it's like I
got a C in health and I are in so much
trouble
yeah but then what happened to your
brother when he got D's and F's well I
think he had a lower expectation yes
usually I never took health because I
took the higher math class when it
happened during though I took a higher
math class ii never took second bunch of
higher math class right now
unbeliev
AP Calculus i'm just sharing this it's a
broken system that although it's like
one time well he's like one time my
friend trying to bounce a quarter off my
ass there ricocheted because my ass is
too tight
you have faked it you know I don't know
why you know no it was a middle school
it was a middle school they thought it
actually don't know why should that
story I love it
I'm gonna say this kid you had your
chance alright you did get to talk about
dicks and that like disease dips we
didn't see any disease dead I took the
school of internet later true you let
him you never quite see the inside of a
dick you know I'm saying
like all that you can see the
cauliflower dicks oh wait what call our
dicks
oh yeah there's dicks Tiger alcohol far
that's true remember that guy that adult
that he went to go play at he was a
college basketball player that wanted to
play at a high school I remember oh yeah
the difference was he actually killed it
and he was like a high school so hard he
got to he was a big fish in a small pond
dude that case he's still a [ __ ]
loser he wasn't even called she was 25
that's like that's like Kobe play him
pick me up basketball pick me up basket
man pick me up where he where somebody
picks him up and dunks him basketball
yeah
pick me a basketball is literally what
this kid is playing like somebody up pls
iceplug it suck I could get a Nicki to
dunk if I pick her up on a fisher-price
[Music]